en début est ma soeur qui font des
crayats et leurs vibrations vama c est
cette fois l'acupuncture du visage
et surtout pour les personnes qui
travaillent devant des ordinateurs feu
ici beaucoup les muscles des yeux a
projeté la pareille à vélo couché dans
leur mettre par terre n'ont pas de gêne
et ici on va passer l'autre là et sans
avoir à lever ces on va ramener le
stream à hauteur de m
rosereau merveille le thermos cap cet
appareil est un radiateur ventilateur
actionné par fil avec lenval colle à
l'intérieur le tout enfermé dans un
cadre en plexiglas radiateur autonome à
chauffage localisé à réal préventique
enduropale vous pourrez rouler sans
crainte en scooter ou affrontez une
expédition collègues
le saint est à la mode et se portera
plus encore gonfler au chalumeau cette
nouvelle forme de soutien gorge à
volumes compensée permettra à chacune
d'avoir à volonté les avantages qui
convienne à sa toilette